I got you what is something there's a
machete in here oh it's right there just
song
oh [ __ ] in here just pick a spot I'm
loaded in should be hand-to-hand combat
for a little while in the beginning
right at the beginning of it well let's
go just has a bra you can go naked
basically all right Frank you tell us
where to drop okay we open this where we
have any where we're at later okay this
is not starting well I'll tell you that
right now all right we're gonna go right
here you see where I dropped on the mat
yeah yeah yeah so just follow it on the
thing now job oh my god honestly I would
see Frank to the toward the highest no
it's not towards the island yeah it's
right here not toward done oh yeah
we're the little towers and [ __ ] okay
where where right right by the water
there's like this whole town alright
oh god I can't get over there oh this is
you have no control over where you're
going
the graphics are so shitty why do people
like this it's better on PC what's this
[ __ ] would pop in though this texture
problem is about crap looking at this
water table I'm landing on a [ __ ]
roof I can't even turn my guy I'm I'm
dead I know I fell in the [ __ ] oh my
god wait building is the worst place
that we landed would eat all right we
landed in a swamp Frank
oh yeah grief so wake our because the
the [ __ ] building popped in I died in
like the wall Christ you can see my body
hanging inside the building is there
anything yeah where I died
okay Cove illuminates what's bullet
loops okay
Coke's not here all right pick up this
the ammo for it or just a gun yeah gun
this gun and ammo there friend
all right all right I'm making my way
down you guys there's a stun grenade to
love it load your [ __ ] oh you're right
you're right you know what I need is a
[ __ ] backpack already I'm already
full I know you know that's the first
thing is a backpack and a vest and a
helmet are the three good first things
everything upstairs now there's some
ammo this echo is so annoying and it's
you Frank because we were playing
earlier and there was no at
at all I was there an echo for mine
isn't your connect or some my there's a
bow and arrow do I want this no no
that's a waste it's oiss you never got
good alright I'm making my way to you
guys all right you guys better go check
some other buildings and get some [ __ ]
cuz hey Craig no backseat uh [ __ ]
driving we don't need your shitty
leadership from the dead zone you know
the [ __ ] pedophile alright um I need
some [ __ ] man do you guys got any
bandages we good
oh this is a weird place for at all got
him in the water how do I get up get up
do not drown do not oh my god you can't
climb up how do you get up you got a
fall all the planks this is up this
actually a good place to defend you know
yeah alright is there a way to get
upstairs here because there's like a
plant going up to the other side other
building if we get upstairs to the roof
where's the stairs into some
[ __ ] Jesus guys how do you keep
there's no stairs
oh here we go here we go are you gonna
warm up the nachos a good thing you guys
are in the zone at least we're in the
zone
oh here we go here we go how do I get
here we go need a [ __ ] backpack no oh
there's a I can't I can't pick up this
shotgun found a Bentley I I have too
much [ __ ] I have too much [ __ ] I have to
get rid of something like why do I have
a [ __ ] um let me get some helmets I
need to draw I got it
there's bandages to your left Griffin
what Oh see that there's bandage right
there I can't even pick it up though I
don't know no space oh that sucks okay
we'll get a backpack oh there's so much
[ __ ] up here guys there's like boots and
[ __ ] yeah we're doing hella good because
we're like in the zone a helmet hey [ __ ]
with all this what's that food and [ __ ]
up here how do you get down
what does it a fly or something a
first-person waiter host close post
close the connection Craig it I swear to
God I swear to God connect back in can I
get back in you can connect back and I'm
looking back there I swear to God I
didn't [ __ ] do that
what just happened yeah you see what
happened Craig's like all I died in the
beginning [ __ ] you I want to start again
no dude I don't play like Pikachu I
don't know I wouldn't do that exactly
what I'm saying you got you're not
saying anything cuz I didn't do anything
yeah yes you did I think it's just a lag
or something because I know that was
some [ __ ] dude I you can watch some
classic I support a Craig nonsense right
there everybody best start ever ruined
in my chat some I'm not stating [ __ ]
I did not [ __ ] if I did that [ __ ] I
would definitely admit it I'd be like
yes [ __ ] you guys are the worst I think
it was just glitchy I don't know what
the [ __ ] this whole game is glitch
don't give it all the glitchy excuse man
go ahead Frank tell us where we're going
hopefully it doesn't glitch out yeah
phantom phantom glitch again Hey look
let's go right here oh you can watch my
um my video let's go to the mansion so
yeah okay no I don't see three I don't
know three two and drop yeah well my
next day where are you guys I don't even
see you guys I see you Frank I'm now if
you dive straight down and hit 220 your
parachute all open up later yeah well I
don't even see are we going am I headed
to the right place you're behind us yeah
it looks like you're coming towards us
we're going to this little like field
right here right with all these people
yeah I mean with this little all these
houses right here Ron had it yeah it's
completely different
I don't know we all going to this place
okay we are going to I'm trying to I'm
trying to [ __ ] down the right ways
[ __ ] on this guy there's a bunch of
people to the right of us just glide
imagine well it's not even rendering
properly
oh [ __ ] I'm getting a gun right here
alright get it loaded because there's
people near us I got a shotgun back okay
I got a shotgun ready to go son say oh
but is it a vest here I got a backpack
oh there's a bunch of [ __ ] in here
there's a 12-gauge in here if you guys
come in here there's an a cake Craig
Craig get some girls you have butter on
me oh yeah thank you it uh oh here's our
guide pack Pikachu I got all [ __ ] here's
a good gun right here oh wow this is
good we got alright wait
anyways what
make sure you pace your [ __ ] to full
auto mama oil giant there's gas can over
here I'm gonna take this shotgun to let
me know firing in full auto rifles who
doesn't want your [ __ ] in here guys if
you guys don't have a backpack let me
know there's one over here I'm coming
right now there's the back I'm like it's
an Imagine second second level
oh god is like there's three backpacks
where I am right here I'm coming in
level yeah level there's three level one
backpacks right here Facebook oh you
know Vantage's yeah if you come in the
house that I'm in there's like a lot of
[ __ ] in here a lot of [ __ ] here's a
first-aid kit
oh man we hit the jackpot in this house
[Music]
no another room there well I think we
get really good in this house I got
there Oh does anyone see any rifles I
can stag I didn't see rifles us our
handguns which there's a lot of hanging
gospel oh I don't know why I'm following
oh no this is Frank us okay what you
gotta find out bass yeah all the
bandages in here you know I got a first
aid case what we got in here
Oh par for 70 now there you go yeah get
that
[ __ ] this all right we giving we gonna
go to the zone don't we
how do you write bumper all right
oh [ __ ] somebody's shooting yeah it's
for a while it's a wild wire okay I want
some [ __ ] reload oh no no no we need
to find a car maybe what's out here
that'd be good I said well I think I'm
ready to move on mm-hmm is there
anything any small zone guys we just get
a kick towards yeah oh you sure have
never city that is oh my guys we got to
go we got to go all right where are you
guys all right let's go
is anybody gonna mark it mark it mark
the zone here I'll mark it [ __ ] oh you
get all that [ __ ] quick-draw mag all
right a zone I don't even know if I have
the right wish I the best [ __ ] I'm
coming are we going there's a tommy gun
right here that's yeah I gave some
holographic sights guys there's
monographic say I'm ready yeah we got we
got a we got a minute 30 dude we got a
book hey you ever see how Craig is
already like way ahead
like not even waiting yeah you normally
do how do you put your gun away
oh my oh why okay are we putting
something on the map where are we going
are we going the right direction yeah
the blue dot the blue dot oh yeah we're
gonna keep people up here yeah these
houses yeah
it have your guns ready though just in
case Gavin Oh Pikachu yeah we don't want
to do are you playing with us are you
[ __ ] joking off somebody right now
what are you doing what are you talking
about where are you going I mean we got
a ways to go do we got a book yeah we
got 15 seconds before the song starts
going yeah we have plenty of time to get
there don't eat all the nachos we have
oh my oh oh I see a buggy if I here's a
buggy [ __ ] nachos one more touch okay
I'll get two of you if two of you want
to grab it I'm gonna run it two of you
can grab this buggy go go let's go um no
no no you guys are good I need to be on
foot I'm gonna scout ahead
well [ __ ] Pikachu go with Griffin all
right somebody could okay okay good to
have two people they can't really shoot
from that but yeah yes you can't shoot
Craig right now I just run em over I
mean that's what the fans want you know
what I mean no they don't
if it was Steve all destroyed
oh you guys just so slow we're doing it
are we almost there
I hear some fighting in our so we're
gonna hit this farm what are we gonna do
I say we go straight into the zone cuz
it's gonna shrink again right after we
get there yeah once we get that's gonna
shrink again let me see where's the map
okay I see what you're saying it yeah
let's just go straight there's a buggy
to the left
hey Griffin Oh Craig or Pikachu go
straight to the left there's another
buggy someone jump out and then drive
and pick us up where is there is it 260
straight ahead Oh
260 okay I don't see it yeah I'm being
Asian right now I can't see what yeah I
don't see me buggy where you where I
think somebody grabbed it there's like
there's somebody driving up there and
there's someone up there
on the top of the hill yeah I don't see
me buggy like what are you seeing
I don't know we're gonna the zone
shrinkage right here we're straight
ahead where I'm running to hey you
better watch your tone buddy yeah I saw
some people around here be careful they
were on top of that hill
and where's that drop happening oh there
it is here's a buggy right here we're
almost all there all right grab that
[ __ ] they can get it there's any package
huh oh [ __ ] and get shot wherever I see
down [ __ ] you oh my god he ran me over
well that's good luck if you get that
bug drive off off off
drive off Trevor hi where we going where
we going oh I don't know we just gotta
go in the zone oh there you are okay
yeah there's a gunner babies baby we're
behind just keep going straight leg he's
dead again trying to kill us
yeah yeah I got shot and [ __ ] run
over there they followed a Frank okay
Pickens you can shoot him he's gonna
bite did they'll be stupid to follow him
yeah they stopped think Frank's still
looking for coke sorry I couldn't hear
you from dying all the time no he's not
coming
let's just go wait a minute get the map
I know we're in a good spot yeah but we
should go to the center we gotta we
gotta find a house or whatever to camp
out at George port we just start heading
there wait right I'm gonna put a thing
on the map I'm gonna put a thing on the
map all right how do you do it how do
you set a thing please
oh I see okay there you go the yellow
one yeah I'll see that
that's gonna be like where it's gonna be
I think you guys look cool like Mad Max
yeah yeah whatever
yeah we did take it out of this game I
swear to god oh my god oh dude then I'm
not I'm not gonna be the [ __ ] I'm
telling you right now I'm just I'm not
even moving the character I'm just gonna
watch Griffin because I don't want to
[ __ ] risk it
there we go all right okay this is good
we're good right now did you hear
somebody all right so what do you think
over here should we hit these now check
out here yeah check the Sims let me see
what we are in the map oh [ __ ] we're
almost to the left is the danger zone oh
wow you know what we should probably
head more center yeah yeah because it's
gonna it's gonna keep okay here we go
right here
these are the mood all right let's go
you see that a yellow mark let's just
head to that
oh [ __ ] doing stunt jumps this trick
play area two minutes I think we're
doing good yeah we're doing great fifty
someone left the live let's check this
one out
all right we're right behind you I don't
think it's been hit yeah we're gonna
leave our buggies here yeah how did you
get out oh there we go oh this isn't it
yeah my sweet I'm glad stairs some pants
and [ __ ] all right I'm coming with you
all right I'm gonna I'll go all the way
up in on the roof
police vest oh yeah here on a roof I
should probably get this switch to a K
yeah yeah that looks like a better gun
you guys have a police that's already
right here's this ammo though I can tell
you Griffin has a vest okay
fully auto all right there's a lot of
[ __ ] up here there's a I don't want that
I don't need are you see anybody no all
right this is good this is good wait
where's the play area oh we're already
in the deep center man I'm gonna hop on
that how's that view from that rooftop
it again that's good that's good that's
a conference I'll get this I'll get low
though and we know how you get oh yeah
Craig you get pretty low and then what
you die oh yeah
Frank's with all the jokes that no
camera running money let's see your new
hour
a scarf the old one I hear somebody
where yeah nobody seems dumb [ __ ] no it
said no I'm hearing something like a
motorcycle no you're not thank you you
seem you want to like hold this area
yeah let's show them kill each other
where you guys all that lets a hold a
place wow this is the there's only one
door which is pretty good but it's kind
of open out here if they weren't even it
Gavin oh my god you see that was hard I
didn't say it did I say I didn't say I
did not say it yeah they're almost
halfway marker you see that drop crepe
no did it drop close because that shit's
got good stuff dude I got a ghillie suit
yeah brains sniper rifle it's tricky
three alive I think we were smart to
come here like this yeah yeah but it
doesn't remove the mark now I think I'd
be good for now and then we'll know if
someone's coming is like trying to take
her cars or whatever yeah where's the
car oh yeah we got a good look get a
good shot at the cars from right here
yeah or somebody should just watch that
door though
I can't from here
yeah shotguns not gonna be good anyway
from that range because it's let's to
it's more sure oh I don't know I still
had that stupid shotgun
yes what say okay there you go what can
I get a shot oh yeah I can shoot from
here right yeah okay I got a good shot
all right 50 alive halfway up should
your right outside the circle guys your
brother though that's fine that's fine
is fine we have two minutes we got two
minutes we could chill people are gonna
try and come to our zone we can kill
them take their lose okay yes can't for
no no we don't need that [ __ ] come on
watch the door yeah watch the door
can't believe those guys got me at the
top of the hill [ __ ] yeah from that
range to I don't know what he saw me
with oh well that's not a horrible in
the heck oh yeah bad why we have echo no
idea oh my god should we / live with
what what's it billing we got our
buggies it's movie on 10 seconds and ten
seconds yeah because we're basically
like right there just gonna go down cuz
I'm gonna put a spot on the map that's
the middle of that circle okay let's go
yeah it looks pretty open because how do
you get down from here by there you go
oh yeah they're getting on the buggy
peaks I know I'm coming we just jumped
off the roof what are you doing
alright there you go
there's like no buildings in this middle
area so it's gonna be pretty open we
should try and I don't know where we're
gonna hide I was good I always go in the
shade and on a higher there's a building
let's try and get to it first and take
over it where's that was that was that
was that where that behind you mind you
to love just keep on straight people are
straight I don't know where but it's to
the right of us alright well we're fine
it's a building over here on the right
all right let's go to it
you okay Franklin thank you yeah oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm watching that by now okay these
buildings over here probably take in
yeah I see a lot you see where the guys
at should we try to take these buildings
I'm just looking look at the math or
dead center this is dead center this is
this is it right here our buggies huh
let's go to war France going like it's
like
should we take this out of any scopes do
you have any Smiley's that's we oh [ __ ]
we run the obscure --tz-- wait a minute
let me redo them let me redo the thing
yesterday you guys are too risky back
home you guys you guys are pretty good
though
yeah let them let them fight it out it's
pretty close and small there's a lot of
people still alive 44 people yeah a lot
of people [ __ ] that's a lot yeah I
thought I put them all there's the mark
yeah let's just try and stay on the very
outer skirt it should be okay there's
one running oh yes run his ass over oh
[ __ ] he's trying to shoot where's that I
can't even see I'm buying oh yeah
train is a sit over where is he over me
I got to run you over by accident you
see where we are in the map oh we're
dead center this is like perfect 30
alive oh my god I'm doing good I'm
watching her behind
where's the [ __ ] strap yeah where is
that 30 seconds
I can't see it well there it is it's
still right there's a Jeep in front of
us there's a Jeep in front of us
we're right down there down there
trevore everywhere my gosh if I run into
Frank one more time I swear to God are
they chasing us I don't know what we
should do we should stay in our cars it
seems like everyone else is in a vehicle
there's like no buildings no and they're
still hella people alive well this
building right here from this is the
only one yeah but the circle is gonna
get even smaller right or will it be
still no Circle Circle did you get that
building hold up if we have you in that
building right here is this even a built
yeah yeah yeah it would take it yeah
this right here yeah [ __ ] yeah even
here careful again nobody in there
nobody in there Oh all right dude you
guys are not this dude I'll just stay in
there stay low close the door close that
door well Frank still driving around
like a crazy person
oh you guys are like hey Craig getting
ready to take a picture and a screen
shot okay I mean I have a coordinate how
do you wait how do you get my oh [ __ ]
okay now I don't fire okay guys that was
an earful switch the shotgun there's
some yeah and watch the door watch the
door watch the door see him see I got
the window I don't see anybody okay I
got you what is something there's a
machete in here oh it's right there just
saw oh [ __ ]
[Music]
we can't see oh that was such a smart
move
oh [ __ ] are you coming at us
[ __ ] you like you like right there
whatever reloaders yeah wait wait wait
single fire mode
I killed my gun I'm gonna interact his
door he's down well you got him back in
the building yes Lucas [ __ ]
what you got always got bandages okay
pick up yeah I get back take it level
two backpack I'll take you know you hear
that really get back in the building
get back in the building and I'll come
out and if they get hella close a smoker
name the door I can't I can't okay just
jump in sixteen oh this is go time
there's actually 13 because three of you
are considered part of that I hope what
they what this [ __ ] is explosive and
they just throw it yeah we just the
whole building out don't can't believe
that I can't believe that dude didn't
get anything he shot he threw that stun
grenade it was a beautiful beautiful
stun grenade we should just get down to
15 a lot I get hectic where's Frank the
Blues come I'm outside he's going he's
he's trying to cover it outside the
Blues on it they're gonna be running
towards you okay Frank you say you're
low
I'm good I'm good
here he come make sure you're watching
that door cuz they could sneak from
around from the left of you you can stay
now Pikachu like I have a good view of
like outside oh good the circle closed
you're still in it you're still in it
the circle closed are still in it are we
oh [ __ ]
well we're barely in it how do you zoom
in it's good to know oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're so still in it
there's actually eight because you guys
are considered three of them equip this
machete no that's stupid no just watch
that door though watch that watch that
door is the circle gonna get even
smaller
we have to move all we got to do a bug
in this [ __ ] yeah you guys oh it's me
there's a guy to the left no no no stay
stay stay where you are you got you got
control of it nice Frank someone's
coming someone's shooting me you want to
come in the room i man over here damn
Frank's for Kerrang skeletal short
careful
a player is getting smaller let's see
where it goes after circle closes phone
what does that mean that means going on
your belly
oh don't let him see you I don't think
it's getting smaller
yeah we still in it yeah we're still in
it we're still in it this is it I think
this is oh yeah now you gotta move we
gotta move come on come on come on yeah
you guys drive around and I'll distract
him well we headed in the right
direction that way now we are to the
street okay all right all right that's
it you're there we're in it let's get
out of this [ __ ] there's a walk right
here I have a first-aid kit you guys
walk
are we not an ear on your outside notes
here oh [ __ ] I got shot guys give me up
oh come toward you Pikachu going keep
going keep going keep going
I'm behind you Pikachu
okay careful careful of reload well he's
behind us there's one behind us to
Griffin reload I can't reload I'll
switch guns in reloading oh [ __ ] where
they are I don't have any more bullets
who's shooting up behind you he's right
over there by the trees why am i [ __ ] is
shooting a shotgun at the guy in the
trees why it gets hectic in the end
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]